hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday July 6 2020 what's going on
and how are you how is how was your
fourth of July weekend you have some
burgers ah yes my [ __ ] french fries
we did you did you make a 7-foot hot dog
and your [ __ ] neighbor was eating one
side and you eat another you know and he
got mad because he ate seven inches and
you only got five the [ __ ] selfish
[ __ ] then you both walked away right is
that what happened or did you just say
and you [ __ ] just had a party I don't
know I didn't do [ __ ] I was just over
here with the wife and kids I got the
grill going and we just did burgers and
dogs nice and [ __ ] simple and that
was it I kind of lived vicariously
through other people's [ __ ] [ __ ] that
they were doing all the fireworks out
here was great watching everybody
shooting him off and all that stuff you
know it's always unfortunate there's
always somebody [ __ ] you know blows
one of their balls off every year hear
about that kid over in Salem ah dude he
had a [ __ ] pack of firecrackers in
his right pocket blew his left nut off
that's what's weird that well evident Lu
how it happened oh did you hear about it
it's my [ __ ] story evidently the
concussive force of the [ __ ]
explosion when it hit his right ball
what actually happened was his right
ball was so concussed by the explosion
was thrown back like [ __ ] Rambo you
know after he blows up a building and it
slammed into the net left nut so hard
that it did disintegrated
it was [ __ ] weird it was like
everybody was looking you know they saw
the one nut in there and it was they
thought it was the left ball turned out
it was the right one
so like that movie faceoff with John
Travolta and [ __ ] Nic Cage switched
faces you know know who's who right
that's gonna be the next thing that they
reboot I'm gonna have that I want to
pitch that over at Netflix a reboot of
face off or it's about a kid whose blows
off his left ball and everybody thinks
it's his right ball you know and then I
get a couple of big celebrities to do
the voices to the balls you know I'm
just roughing this out here okay and if
you think you're gonna beat me over to
the writers guild to register this idea
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
okay this is gonna be my next big score
in the middle of this pandemic okay and
I've been scoring right and [ __ ] left
all right Bert Kreischer introduced me
to the wonders of a heath bar I had one
of those today you know it was very
happy I didn't have any fillings in my
mouth delicious candy bar that was a
[ __ ] score isn't there a candy bar
named score isn't there I have no
[ __ ] idea
anyways god bless everybody went out
there and had a good [ __ ] time you
know breathing on people and shooting
off fireworks you know la there's no
City I would say no city in the [ __ ]
world that it has the level of just
random do you ever see the Stanford
[ __ ] college band you know they're
whole hey hey man don't ever watch that
bin the level of murderous thoughts that
goes through your [ __ ] head with
those [ __ ] [ __ ] all full of
themselves like what they're doing is so
avant-garde it's just I get I get it I
get it you know you could have actually
got together and done something instead
you chose to do nothing and now you're
acting like you're actually thinking
outside the box when you're really just
laying on your [ __ ] back playing a
trumpet which anybody else in any other
band could [ __ ] do you know we don't
have uniforms man [ __ ] Stanford we're
crazy
I feel like LA's fireworks is like that
you know what I mean LA's fireworks is
like if the Stanford marching band was
exciting I will forever hate that
[ __ ] band because I went to a Rose
Bowl game
it was Stanford verse Iowa and the band
played the farmer the Stanford band
played the farmers only
theme song you don't have to be lonely
at farmersonly.com they [ __ ] on these
people they were guests in this state
and they [ __ ] on him and they did that
classic [ __ ] you know we live on the
coast we live near an ocean therefore
we're more intelligent than you are
farmers are growing our [ __ ] food the
[ __ ] are you doing building a website go
[ __ ] yourself having said that what a
beautiful campus Stanford has you know
what I mean if you had to choose between
the two you got to go Stanford you
definitely the move there was there was
no reason they know that I and what they
know you're Stanford they know you got
better-looking broads you didn't have to
rub their [ __ ] noses in it
came out to this state with that best
[ __ ] overalls on trying to have a
good [ __ ] time and what did you
[ __ ] rich [ __ ] do you're right you
didn't even have to do it you could have
just been rich [ __ ] you know if you
could have just been now you had to rub
their face in it I was like you know
what [ __ ] this bad I would never say
[ __ ] that school it's a great school and
I also liked the football team but [ __ ]
that [ __ ] band [ __ ] [ __ ] bunch
of [ __ ] band geeks and then who got
bullied in high school right you know
got beaten with their own [ __ ]
clarinet and what did they learn all
that pain all that sniffling is they
were driving you know cry and practice
and later on that's I'm trying to play
the blow the [ __ ] horn what did they
let they turn around and they repeat the
behavior unforgivable
[ __ ] that bad alright any time anybody
brings up the band at the moment that
everybody just loves to hate on I go hey
what about this Stanford marching band
anyway if I see one more ad for a
posture corrector whatever they call it
fix your posture it's like I get it
you're watching
me I understand I've never actually I
clicked on at one time maybe that's what
it is I've been trying to be more
cognizant of the way that I sit in that
type of [ __ ] you know cuz right now like
the move you know everybody out there
with the newborn baby right you guys you
know the move right you if you have one
of those exercise balls I don't know
what it is but you put the baby in your
beautiful baby in your arms and you just
you just sort of bounce up and down on
the ball right and it just I don't think
it simulates like riding in the car is
another thing that just makes them fall
asleep so I got it down I got it down to
a science
I got it down like I get my son to so
fall asleep that like I mean I set him
down like I set down my books after
school well not that hard but I mean for
a baby it feels that hard cuz with my
daughter I was like oh oh my god and I
just feel like they can feel your no
don't cry and then they start crying cuz
they don't they'll get dog they just
reacting to your vibes man so with this
one I'm just like you know what he's
asleep I'm gonna stand up normally and
I'm gonna walk over and just set him
down like I'm putting a drink on a table
and that's what I've been doing and this
little champ has been just just just
sleeping like last night I got to go
from let's see about 12:30 at night to
4:00 in the morning already
precious precious three and a half hours
of sleep and then I was up for an hour
and then I got to sleep for another
three hours that's fine I'm cool with
that
I'm cool like that I'm something like
that get it do it do whatever that
[ __ ] early 90s hip-hop was that I
missed out on all of it because I was
too busy Statten out as a comic I've
been posting some of this [ __ ] that I
find finally cleaned out my office my
office is it's done except for a couple
of photos that I want to put up I got
one of me and Patrice I got one a John
Bonham when he's behind his green
sparkle kit and a couple others then I
don't be done with my office and now for
the first time in years I love my office
I can move around and
it's [ __ ] nice as opposed to stepping
over [ __ ] and just thinking you know at
some point at some point I really need
to organize my stuff and I finally did
it
for the most part it's like 85%
organized and then I just got excited I
just threw the last two [ __ ] boxes in
a closet and I was like guys that's it
I'm done I'm done and the reality is
what is so funny about all of that [ __ ]
it's all memorabilia and stuff from my
past and everything other than some
family photos and [ __ ] and pictures with
friends the reality is is if you took
all of that away from me you know first
of all how long it would take for me to
even notice that it was gone and I would
get rid of all of it but I it's just
gonna end up in a dump somewhere so I
feel like if I keep it in my closet at
least animals won't have to deal with it
until after I'm dead that's what's
amazing with plastic and [ __ ] like how
long you're gonna be continuing to
pollute the planet after you're dead and
I really think that we have solutions to
all of this [ __ ]
if these money-grubbing [ __ ] old
families would just get the [ __ ] out of
the way that's that's a stupid [ __ ]
statement I just if the mindset of a
corporation could just change we could
just do the [ __ ] right thing would be
tremendous which I think eventually we
will get to and I think like most things
we're gonna wait to the last second I'll
get better before it get worse before it
gets better
who the [ __ ] knows but I am out here
right now in my office my now clean
office that I am I'm hanging out here
and I I gotta put my daughter to bed
here in about eight minutes so I wanted
to knock out a few minutes of this
podcast at least a couple of minutes is
what I wanted to do and then I'll do the
rest of it so they'll be a little bit of
a jump here but you're not gonna notice
cuz I'm gonna [ __ ] edit it out
obviously full disclosure and then I got
a obviously then I gotta go back in the
house and [ __ ] deal with
yep the rest of my night which my son is
been real good about sleeping after
midnight I can't get too mad at dad he
gets a little fussy 10:30 to midnight
and that's when you just have to like
step up as a debt and that's the one
thing that I have really really learned
is just how much breastfeeding takes out
of the woman the woman it's she my wife
file just goes bill you have to
understand they're literally sucking
they literally sucked the life out of
you
and I was just like you know what I get
it I finally get it cuz I'm looking like
what the [ __ ] you just sitting there you
know you know it's not you have to
concentrate to make milk your body does
it on its own there's being a typical
dumb guy right and then you you'll
freakin hook the kid up then you just
sit there you know watching your shows
and then the kids done and then I gotta
you know I gotta you know change of them
and rock them and Birbhum and do all of
this other stuff I didn't realize you
got to keep feeding your wife you're
breastfeeding wife and that and then you
just you just you got to [ __ ] be
there man you got to be that unselfish
person in the locker room wherever you
need that's what you do I cook dinner
tonight I cooked the lunch I cooked the
brag do all of that [ __ ] I do all the
[ __ ] dishes I am putting on a [ __ ]
clinic enough I could just somehow not
lose my temper once every 36 hours at a
Bobby Knight level you know I think I
think I'd have something here I think I
would actually have a think I would have
a happy woman okay every married guy's
fantasy a happy wife what what do I need
to do you know that's all I need to know
so anyway I was watching my little champ
today and I recorded a couple of things
off of TBS
some old movies and I actually watched
the Boston Strangler the Boston
Strangler starring Tony Curtis Henry
Fonda and George Kennedy among others a
bunch of character actors in that and I
loved a great movie what's-his-face was
incredible Tony Curtis was amazing and
obviously Henry Fonda's always great
George Kennedy was amazing but so much
of like the dialogue and stuff is so
funny and you really can see like oh
this is how the guys who did airplane
like because so much that meant movie
was like really serious movie and now
you watch it and so much of it is comedy
the flippin way you know talking about
gay people using the f-word it's just
like just flying around like it's
nothing - no no this really like
progressive sort of movie about mental
health but like you know that word you
know they hadn't had that whole thing
going hey stop and [ __ ] knock it off
whatever the hell they said a few
decades ago you know which is also why
you can't go back in time and look at
[ __ ] and be like um what the [ __ ] is up
with John Wayne what the [ __ ] I mean
that that [ __ ] I swear to God it's
literally like that is such lazy like
grandstanding by [ __ ] white people I
am so mad at dead for 40 years John
Wayne [ __ ] idiots
yeah I think I think really you should
you should probably focus on the people
that are alive right now who could
actually hurt or help people is probably
what you want to start with you know I
get the statue's thing I get it whatever
[ __ ] II get it to me it's maybe it would
be basically this kind of thing if the
Germans won and then you stay [ __ ] but
they kept like Jewish people around they
got a look at like statues of Hitler and
after a while they they're gonna tear
them down
and then all the Germans jeez a [ __ ]
good guy I like his Mustang you know it
was a long time ago I get it I get all
of that [ __ ] I don't get after you knock
it down than the dude coming over and
kicking the statue in the head it's like
it's an inanimate object it's down it's
on the ground silver it's kind of a punk
move I thought you know what I mean you
know I mean there's always that gaiden I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's a real person
or if it's a statue when somebody gets
knocked down to the ground there's
always that [ __ ] [ __ ] runs over and
then kicks the the person of the statue
in the [ __ ] head in the head huh
sorry boys cracking here anyway so I
watched that movie was amazing it was
about this this serial killer in Boston
and he was strangling women and all of
this [ __ ] killed like 13 women
terrorized Boston for like two years I
believe around the time of the Kennedy
assassination and and then of course
there was all these conspiracy he wasn't
him and the reason why the Boston
strangler's stopped the second they
arrested this guy is because he wanted
it all get blamed on him of whatever
2013 they had the DNA [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they I don't know somehow they got to
semen somewhere maybe just to shut it up
I don't know what they figured out that
they actually got the right guy now his
here's the difference of how times
change okay because if there was first
of all somebody strangling women in
Boston a serial killer they wouldn't
call him the Boston Strangler they
wouldn't they they would be something
else I don't know somehow the I don't
know the neck violating [ __ ] I don't
know what a toxic male I don't know what
the [ __ ] they thought they would come up
with something rather than the Boston
Strangler but this is how different [ __ ]
was back then there was a guy in Boston
Sirica was strangling women so his name
was the Boston Strangler okay within 20
years of that a man named Andrew Tony
playing for your Philadelphia 76ers used
to come in and light the Celtics up he
would put on a display of shooting I
swear to God I Steph Corrine
foreshadowing Steph Curry okay his
greatest games okay and he was way
cooler than Steph Curry because he was
older than me and I still thought at
that point maybe I could make the NBA
now Steph Curry's just some young kid
that you know whose dream happened and
mine didn't I wanted that dunk you know
I wanted to hit the big three backpedal
and down the court before it even went
in I wanted to do that at the Pok a
there in [ __ ] Boston Garden people
chant mine anyway so his nickname was
the Boston Strangler cuz he would come
to town and he would [ __ ] kill us he
would [ __ ] kill us and I'm trying to
think of any [ __ ] way in modern times
that light yeah was who's that kid who
just won the Superbowl there in Kansas
City I swear to God my short-term memory
the second this season is over the [ __ ]
is that guy's name he won a ring but my
respect on his name what the [ __ ] is his
name I can't remember his [ __ ] can you
imagine if he got named after like cuz
he kills people with two minutes left on
the clock and then they they give him
the same nickname assists is if Jeffrey
Dahmer had a [ __ ] nickname hey H
defense is alive keep it going for
whatever is far man I had it I got the
joke I just don't have the [ __ ]
reference what is his [ __ ] name what
is your name by the way how about the
pagers get in Cam Newton Cam Newton
let's see here just when you thought the
Patriots were dead Rich Eisen and if you
guys saw me I had a greatest time when
Rich Eisen and the man knows how to get
me going right before the interview he
sent me a bunch of pictures of Tom Brady
in a Tampa Bay Buccaneer uniform let's
say que si QB
Patrick mahomes that's not funny right
before it came up I I just I just
immediately I saw it because I knew the
answer was gonna be there I stopped
stressing my brain and then it just
floated right to me keep it going for
Patrick Jeffrey Dahmer my Holmes
never would happen well Jeffrey Dahmer
didn't have a nickname let's let's look
at top serial killer nicknames Jesus
Christ what watch lists them I gotta get
on this top serial killer hiding murder
material in his cereal box on top of
your stereo top serial killer killer
Nick nicknames alright here we go
bump up dude oh dude
alright the hillside stragglers the Sun
is Sam the lady killer Ted Bundy was
called the lady killer that almost
sounds like like he's out there crushing
ass not say what Ted Bundy a TAS he
really got in there up sorry
that's actually what Jeffrey Dahmer the
BT Kane was the worst one that's it
that's just a bad one and he gave it to
himself to the Night Stalker the acid
bath murderer what in the [ __ ] oh Jesus
Christ I don't want to know but I don't
want to have you listen you [ __ ]
alright I almost said something really
like I was gonna start hating on those
[ __ ] I'm not I don't want to do it I
don't want to do it okay I am too old to
understand YouTube celebrities there I
said it
okay I understand if you go out you'd go
do some funny [ __ ] but I don't
understand the guys who under women who
are just [ __ ] talking over [ __ ] and
they're just getting in the way of it
it's like are you trying to suggest that
I don't have any friends to joke around
with when I watch it
okay acid bath murderer John hey look at
what this [ __ ] serial killer mustache
1909 to 1949
see what he did with his 40 years on
this earth commonly known as the acid
bath murderer was an English serial
killer who was convicted for the murders
of six people although he claimed to
have killed nine you know that's one of
that's is sort of a reoccurring thing
with the serial killers you know they
are [ __ ] talkers you know you're being
charged with the murder of 16 innocent
people
wait this more 27 keep going
acid bet it was convicted for the
murders of six people though he claimed
to have killed nine hey battered to
death or shot as victims and then
disposed of their bodies using sulfuric
acid before forgoing forging their
signatures so he could sell their
possessions and collect large sums of
money oh that's not that bad I thought
he was throwing him in while they was
still alive so this is like some
Breaking Bad [ __ ] put him in the old
[ __ ] oil drum there so this guy
really wasn't necessary as serial killer
this guy was just a [ __ ] that that's not
a serial killer I thought a serial
killer is like somebody who did just
gotta kill kill somebody this guy is
just like a [ __ ] criminal well I
guess they're both criminals you know me
he's like he's robbing people and he's
just doing it at such a high level we're
gonna come back to this I did why would
I read that and I'm gonna go read a
[ __ ] bedtime story
and you wonder why I'm so [ __ ] up all
right let's see all right let me just
hit stop I'll just paste them together
all right we're going to take a break
and by the magic of editing I would be
back in three two one
okay and I'm back just like that well
the water of any this [ __ ] guy this
John George [ __ ] a
his name is my name too look he's got
though beady eyes he's got the [ __ ]
Hitler stache sort of little Tom Selleck
maybe ties a little crooked looking at
him on Wikipedia this guy was not a
serial killer serial killers don't give
a [ __ ] about your money
they they they want to [ __ ] you know
turn you back into a [ __ ] pantsuit he
was back skin whatever the [ __ ] it is
they've actually battered to death or
shot as victims dispose of their bodies
using sulfuric acid before forging their
signature so he could sell their
possessions and collect large sums of
money yeah this is a [ __ ] scam
he'd forged their signature he could
sell their possessions collect large
sums of money not the brightest guy
early life of Jesus John he grew up in a
village of outward west riding my mama's
parents were engineers and his wife was
a member of the Plymouth Brethren
where'd he get the [ __ ] chemistry
background hey later claimed that he
suffered from reoccurring religious
nightmares in his childhood despite
these limitations he developed great
proficiency at the piano which he
learned at home
he was fond of classical music oh boy
and often went to concerts featuring
music by a bunch of people at Bach
Vivaldi and Tchaikovsky Tchaikovsky
whatever shush off you hubby you said
hey won a scholarship to Queen Elizabeth
the grammar with this [ __ ] guy he's
playing the piano he's getting broads
he's listening to the classic music
classical music I should say what the
[ __ ] happened July 6 1934 hey married 23
year old Beatrice Betty hammer oh look
at their look at that gams on Beatrice
the marriage soon disintegrated the same
year that
he was jailed for fraud Betty gave birth
while he was in prison although she gave
the baby girl up for adoption and let
hay and left hey hey conservative family
ostracize him from then onwards
hey moved to London all right well here
with us kid hey was freed from prison in
1943 and became an accountant with an
engineering firm soon after by chance he
bumped into his former employee William
mix Swan in the goat pub in Kensington
mcc's Wan introduced hay to his parents
Donald and Amy oh boy
McSwain worked for them by collecting
rents on their London properties and hay
became envious of his lifestyle yeah
this guy's not a serial killer this guy
is just a [ __ ] he's a Yolo DOS who
[ __ ] was killing people and then
forging their names all right I mean
serial kills that I think of all right
let's let's get to somebody else here
what are we the top sorry let me get
back to this here Oh for [ __ ] sakes
where did it go where did it go hey you
know you look [ __ ] up and then you click
the back arrow and it just disappears
top 10 serial killer nicknames alright
let's let's we got to get through the
whole [ __ ] list here sorry
it's taking me forever
alright so we're not this [ __ ] [ __ ]
again jesus [ __ ] christ just give me
the list just give me the [ __ ] list I
don't need to here's your stupid
soliloquies I'm doing the soliloquy all
right where are you where are we
acid bath murderer the Cleveland torso
murderer all right the ick factor of the
clove whoever wrote X Factor should have
been the victim of this person the ick
factor how old are you of the he then he
ate the head oh my god
Ecch like talk about
all right let me just [ __ ] him right
sorry it was a little stressful put my
daughter to bed then I couldn't get my
son to stop crying after me talking
about how I had it down I did not have
it down I had a good night I can tell
tonight tonight's gonna be yeah
tonight's gonna be oh it's gonna be a
rough one all right the ick factor of
the Cleveland torso murderer is sheer
body horror is this a review of a movie
during the 1930s a series of human
remains were found in and around
Cleveland Ohio often in the kinseth is
that [ __ ] name again kins burry Run
area
the bodies were typically beheaded or
dismembered and the torsos was sometimes
cut in half hence the nickname the
cleveland torso murderer he murdered the
torso he murdered the people something
wrong with that nickname authorities
weren't always able to identify the
victims either the heads weren't always
found and in some cases death had
occurred several months or a year prior
to discovery 12 victims were religiously
allegedly originally attributed to the
Cleveland sorcerer murderer although the
Lady of the lake who was founded in 1934
before any of the other victims is
thought to be in an additional victim
indeed some theories posit that uh posit
POS I T I don't what that word is that
up the Cleveland torso murder may have
been responsible for up to 20 deaths by
the way the Cleveland torture murder had
a second nickname the mad butcher of
Kingsbury Run yeah that's way better
that's way better than the [ __ ]
whatever the hell she just wrote her he
wrote you know what I'm [ __ ] bored
with this serial killers who have
nicknames see what these people got here
they got 41 of them Milani David
Franklin junior no how not happy is his
dad that he named him after himself the
Grim Sleeper David Berkowitz on a Sam
Gary Ridgway
the Green River Killer Dennis Rader who
really looks like [ __ ] Walter White
he's the BTK guy I don't know he gave
himself the [ __ ] nickname
Richard Ramirez he was the hillside
strangler right was his name
terrorized Los Angeles I was he the 405
[ __ ] what what did they call him Jesus
he's Dennis Nilsen look at that [ __ ]
guy killed people looks like he got
picked on the privileged oh my god the
British equivalent of Jeffrey Dahmer
Nilsson was a gay killer who slayed 15
queer men when the [ __ ] was this written
queer man in his home in London England
between 78 and 83
alright that's five years at 60 months
15 Indus that goes forth once every four
months he kept his victims corpses
before dissecting their remains of
disposing of their bodies by burning or
flushing the remains to the toilet this
led to his capture I would think so when
human flesh was discovered in his sewage
system not the brightest guy all right I
don't want to [ __ ] him I don't wanna be
reading this [ __ ] right before I go to
sleep for a couple hours anyways all
right where are we here well I think
it's time for some advertising all right
a little over a half hour in what do you
say what do you say you do a little bit
of ad reads there all right helix
everybody helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses made right here in America
yeah de bois todo bought a bow and
shipped to you straight to your [ __ ]
goddamn door with free no contact
delivery free returns and a hundred
night sleep trial [ __ ] gross to choose
a mattress hellix made a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete two and a
half of year of [ __ ] dope and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you and your
Bulls if you like
trous that's really soft or firm you
sleep on your side or your back or your
stomach or you sleep really hot I always
hate that line gross the [ __ ] do you got
on your conscious you flip it around
like a goddamn fish with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste I took the quiz
and I would match with I did not take
the quiz
I love helix well I love that you're
advertising but you don't need to take
my word for it hellix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress bite
over here you go you don't need my
[ __ ] me backing it when GQ Wired
magazine and Apartment Therapy just go
to a HELOCs sleep talk calm slash bird
take that two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life we've been
advertising with these people these
people been advertising with us forever
people love these goddamn mattresses
they have a 10 year warranty and you can
try it out for a hundred nights you
[ __ ] animal risk-free they'll leave
it pick it up
leave it pick it up gross and give you a
full refund if you don't love it but you
will I would love to hear those sales
calls when they try to keep you on the
line but what didn't you like about it
well you know I was banging my wife and
I got a charley horse well have you
tried the missionary position well you
know there's too much water under the
bridge I can't look at her face anymore
well I'll write that this is not the
mattress for you right now helix is
offering up to $200 off a mattress
orders for our listeners get up to our
listeners from my listeners get up to
$200 off hellix sleep comm slash BER
alright oh look who's here policy genius
you know people there's never a bad time
to save money but now more than ever
findings sorry finding smart ways to put
some cash back in your pocket can make a
big difference one way to do this is to
simply save on the things you already
paid for like home insurance if you own
a home resharpen your home insurance
rates with policy genius could save you
a good chunk of change in the
best part is you barely need to lift a
finger to do it motivate your audience
hey audience first head to policy genius
comm and answer a few quick questions
about yourself and your property then
policy genius will compare your policy
against options from top insurers to
make sure you are getting the right home
insurance coverage at the best possible
price if policy genius finds you a
better rate than what you're currently
paying they'll do all the work to get
you switched I own a car - policy genes
will compare your home and auto policy
prices across different insurers and
even mix and match to find you savings
this is perfect they save their
customers an average of 1127 dollars and
zero zero cents per year doing just that
who likes to shop for insurance nobody
they're gonna [ __ ] do it for you and
get you the best price I think that's
what they're trying to say here so if
you'd like to put a little cash back in
your pocket right now you can do
whatever you want good I know the titty
bar I throw it around
keep it horde it stuff it in a mattress
whatever it is you do see how much you
can save by reshaping your home
insurance rates at policy genius.com
I was just doing the Trump I had that
you know I had the thing with it with
the two fingers on the thumb so I was
making those points oh and lastly but
not leastly old friends of the podcast
been here for eight years
stamps.com for all of our sakes
yeah sorry that was a long quiet yawn
stamps.com for all of our sakes we need
to do our best to avoid crowds any way
we can right now but what if you need to
go to the post office man what if you
need postage to send out your letters
and packages man that's why you need to
go to stamps come anything you can do
with the post office you can do right
you can do it stamp Starcom print
postage on demand and skip those lines
and crowds at the post office plus you
could actually see yeah you can
literally save your life if you're an
old person okay you know going down to
the post office you can do this with you
at home on your giant computer plus you
can actually save some money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office as if that wasn't good
enough
stamps.com offers you ups always want to
see the other one
ups services UPS United Postal Service
you know how Parcel Service UPS I don't
what the [ __ ] it means UPS services with
discounted discounts up to 62 percent
and no UPS residential surcharges
whether you're a small business sending
invoices and online seller shipping out
products or you're just working from
home and need to mail stuff stamps.com
can handle it all with these simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready just leave
it for your mail carrier schedule a free
package pick up or drop it in a mailbox
no human contact required it's that
simple and like I said with stamps comm
you get discounts you get great
discounts to five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 62 percent
off usps shipping yeah United States
Postal Service that's the one UPS is
United Parcel Service shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time and money and
keeping you safe in these crazy times
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage in a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps con click on the microphone
atop the home page and type in ber be
URR that stamps comm enter / b you are r
stay safe my friends there we go alright
I love those guys but that's a little
[ __ ] long so it's a little long to
sit through you get it you know what to
go to the post office and they save your
[ __ ] money where do I go stamps com
all right that's it enter / alright the
Gulag arch e pala go how do you say that
I'm a political science major great so
you're gonna win arguments and bars how
are you gonna earn money
alright hang on a second AR CH I PE l AG
o pro pronunciation my computer is just
going to start guessing pronunciation on
everything now
I'm a student look at the a archipelago
alright just say it right here we go
archipelago archipelago archipelago
archipelago we spell tat aar dot K you H
that's our archipelago is a pirate word
the Gulag Archipelago dear Billy global
worldwide hmm I'm a political science
major entering my third year in two
different classes we've learned about
the Gulag I'm amazed that it's not
taught in high school it's hard to match
the evils of the Holocaust because it
was such a concentrated hate but the
gulag is right there with it please read
the Wikipedia article on the podcast or
even a whole book sometime PS I agree
Woodrow Wilson was an abomination
yeah he was okay well here we go let's
see here let's look this up gulag why
don't we feel like that's like some sort
of [ __ ] like New Orleans dish you
know in style yeah all right there I
thought what uh what do they call it the
trifecta celery onions and something
else would have the farm just combining
all kinds of [ __ ] Wiki ok gulag ok the
gulag or gulag was the government agency
in charge of the soviet union network of
forced labor camps set up by order of
vladimir lenin reaching its peak during
Joseph Stalin's rule from the 1930s to
the early 1950s English language
speakers also used the word gulag to
refer to forced labor camps that existed
in the Soviet Union including camps that
existed in the post Stalin era the gulag
is recognized as a major instrument of
political repression the Soviet Union
the camp's housed a wide range of
convicts from petty criminals to
political prisoners large numbers of
whom
were convicted by simplified procedures
such as by the bike anymore I don't know
what that word is or by other
instruments okay the internment system
grew rapidly reaching a population of
100,000 1920s all right what did they do
contemporary history background
formation Mort death toll conditions
this is really just a dark podcast
living and working conditions in the
camps varied from significantly it's
very significantly across time in place
depending among other things on the
impact of broader events world war ii
countrywide famine and shortages waves
of terrors sudden influx of releases of
large numbers of prisoners however to
one degree or another the large majority
of the presence this is just not going
to get okay
Schaech the from ghoul egg reconstructed
gulag so you just slept on wood it was
famine severes famine nineteen thirty
one thirty three swept across many
different regions of the Soviet Union
during this time is that's made that
around six to seven million people
starved to death on August 7th 1932 a
new etic drafted by Stalin specified a
minimum sentence of 10 years or
execution for theft from collective
farms yeah I don't want to read about
this this is just terrible [ __ ] how do
you do this to I just do not [ __ ]
understand how human beings can do that
to other human beings alright I'll check
out the Gulag Archipelago I will check
that out
statues verse Biden what say choose the
person wrote si tu es I read as statues
dear Billy principles I think that some
of the Cadiz Confederate statutes
statutes statues are ridiculous
especially since most were put up during
the 1950s and 60s that's a great point
but honestly how are people telling me
to vote for
for Biden who brags to this day about
the crime bill which puts millions of
black men in jail for nonviolent crimes
destroying the male role in so many
communities that guy represents so much
more than the statues and every time I
bring this up which is often people just
look at me like I'm stumping for Trump
I hate everyone's stupid opinion thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself well welcome to my
world
that's where I feel I mean and I also
don't even know what to believe because
there's so much [ __ ] that's attached to
anything that any politician ever signs
you know which I still don't understand
why that isn't legal to do it you know
why it is because they would say no to
it because they get voted out of office
if they did it the fact that [ __ ] gets
attached to bills and everybody's
accepting of that I just think big money
is the attack who the [ __ ] do you know
walking down this what you do today I
attach something to a bill how the [ __ ]
did you do that you don't have any money
I agree with you but I also think at
this point you know I know I'm talking
too much about politics okay
my thing Mike I wanna I want a leader
under center that's what I want okay I
want somebody throws an incomplete pass
comes and says hey my bad doesn't yell
at the [ __ ] wide receivers okay and
has that look in his eye you know like
we're gonna [ __ ] win this and points
out John Candy in the crowd during the
final drive of a [ __ ] Super Bowl
that's what I want in a president
whether he's wearing a blue or a [ __ ]
red tie that's all I need all right go
[ __ ] yourself okay advice sloppy teens
from Elaine hola
Billy blue eyes I live in a unique
neighborhood unique New York
anchorman I live in a unique
neighborhood it's a it's small and as a
private airstrip running through the
middle of it oh that's awesome the
houses on the strip have hangars and
most of the owners are retired NASA in
Air Force pilots with small planes Wow
can you imagine the conversations when
they're [ __ ] talking over the fences
Jesus Christ I bet they all know what
[ __ ] not to talk about
they never have to say it's classified
they just know the areas they can't talk
they probably keep it light you know
what did you shoot any fireworks off for
the 4th ok at the end of the airstrip we
have a private park with trails and a
playground for kids and in the back
there is a creek with a pipeline
crossing it that attracts teenagers
swinging off the pipeline into the creek
and late night drinking / partying it's
been ongoing like this for decades and
the neighborhood residents are always
trying to figure out how to stop the
teenagers from using the park mostly
because of the trash they leave behind
the cops don't do anything except run
them off but they always come back
lately the neighborhood residents have
been trying to figure out a way a real
way to crack down for example towing
their cars and pressing charges
I struggle with it it seems harsh and we
were all teenagers once and had and had
a place to go like this to blow off
steam that's how I look at it if I ever
[ __ ] did that the level of hypocrite
that I would be we used to go we used to
go down this place Dan Road it was like
an office of developing office Park we
used to just like to be like a caravan
alike [ __ ] ten cars just driving down
that office you know area into this one
thing whether it was like a trail it was
like you just all of a sudden you just
be off road and you went all the way
into these like woods well they cleared
out that I'm sure they've now developed
we would just go down there and get
[ __ ] up and you know every weekend
either Friday night or Saturday night a
police cruiser would go down there we'd
all [ __ ] run take off I'd do [ __ ]
whatever so how the hell could I sit
there and cosign on that [ __ ] I mean
if they're doing like meth and [ __ ] and
they're being [ __ ] crazy then yeah
but you know they're just in booze and
weed and [ __ ] you know I don't give a
[ __ ] I gave some goof-off suggests and
such as releasing rabid skunks on them
attacking them with paintball guns and
stealing their booze
or just putting a [ __ ] trash can
there and hopes they would use it I do
enjoy the park with my son and the mess
is actually annoying got any fun ideas
what would you suggest if it was your
neighborhood ie I would probably go down
there and just [ __ ] clean it up
that's what I would do and I would just
do what you did I would have a trashcan
and I would just say you know don't be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] name something has full
Garrity on it so they'll think it's
funny I don't know I remember a long
time ago drink it down the Cape at this
kid's house and this old guy came by and
he was yelling at us so we were drinking
out the front lawn like [ __ ] idiots
underage out in the front yard stupid
right
he just kept yelling at us going like
yeah can't we drive we always had a
barrel barrel kept yelling about having
a trash barrel and looking back the guy
was right now the way he did it was
wrong but um I don't know I can't really
judge any of that cuz I did all of that
[ __ ] many fun ideas what would you do
well you can't [ __ ] with the environment
because that's gonna come back and bite
you in the ass what and what's the you
gonna train these rabid skunks to only
come out after the teenagers you know
then they're not gonna be there and
they're not gonna leave a bunch of [ __ ]
around for the rabid skunks to eat then
eventually they're gonna be in your
garbage so that doesn't work
paintball guns I don't know that's you
know these [ __ ] kids today they can't
handle that [ __ ] they'd somehow take
video and then you get [ __ ] suit sued
stealing their booze really do you
really want a [ __ ] case a key stone
like whenever the hell kids drink
nowadays that cheap ass booze I don't
know what I would do I mean it'd be fun
to [ __ ] with them if you wanted to it
just seems so douchey though you know
something I actually I wouldn't I would
just lie would just let them drink and
have a good [ __ ] time
and just realize that you know they
could be doing a lot worse they could be
doing a lot worse and I you know I don't
know I just go down there I just would
[ __ ] pick this [ __ ] up I've always
done that [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] that
ho ego thing they picking up your
[ __ ] trash I don't want to look at it
so I would I would just go over and I
just pick it up that's what I you know
what I would do I would go over there
before there's other [ __ ] adults got
up and I would go over there and I would
just clean up the [ __ ] area and then
let them think that whatever [ __ ]
thing that they did made those kids go
away and that way the kids can have fun
the adults aren't mad and you get an
exercise picking up the trash there you
go problem solved alright wedding
proposal advice dear bill bald as my
balls bur alright somebody got the
[ __ ] manscape I discovered your
podcast a few months back while working
during this pandemic shout out to all
the essentials and I can't tell you how
much I've been addicted oh that's great
thank you I regularly tune in Mondays
and Thursdays and look forward every
week and I'm currently listening to
earlier podcasts from this year pre
Kovich shitstorm anyway I'm a 24 year
old dude and I've been with my
girlfriend for a couple of years now and
have been thinking a lot lately about
popping the question we are both the
same age and have stable jobs and we
don't see ourselves leaving anytime soon
things are great a relationship your
life just Yannick alright I was
interested in how your proposal to the
lovely Nia went and how you knew it was
the right time and if you were nervous I
knew it was the right time cuz she was
gonna [ __ ] leave me if I didn't I
strung her along as long as I could
[ __ ] could I was terrified I had
totally loved her and I wanted to be
with her but I was scared was i nervous
I absolutely was nervous I'm having
trouble thinking of how I should propose
to her
but I know I want to I know I also know
she's everything I want they
she's definitely what's best for me
that's great you discovered it really
young and she has my best interest in
mind
thanks for whatever advice you can lend
and also thanks for doing the podcast
good [ __ ] lots of love from New England
and I hope your family is safe during
these times go [ __ ] yourself
yeah they I don't know throughout the
years with the Internet and the cell
phone cameras like people really think
they got to do like this big giant
[ __ ] thing I did not do a big giant
thing because I know if I if I tried to
[ __ ] plan anything she would have
figure it out so I went the opposite way
I believe it was Christmas morning we
went on a hike back when we still had my
awesome dog go Cleo do and it had rained
out and it was all muddy and she was
pissed and we were going up this hill
and she just was [ __ ] upset she was
not having a good time and I had no plan
I just think I was going to ask her on
the hike and then we just came to this
rock that had this it just was
overlooking downtown LA and I just told
her to sit down for a second I acted
like I was having trouble with the dog
and asked her if she could reach into my
pocket my jacket pocket and she pulled
it out and it was it was a little
Tiffany box or whatever and she went you
know put her hand over a mouth and just
started sobbing and that was one of the
happiest days of my life not only
because I did it and I felt great and I
knew it was right and I knew it was the
right decision but also when you you
know when you're an [ __ ] like me and
your woman is always mad at you I just
knew for the rest of the day she was
going to be in a good mood and I don't
think I've ever had another day like
that
at any moment I'm telling you today I
fly [ __ ] I have this habit I [ __ ]
get a glass of water I set it down on
the floor I stink to myself bill don't
put it on the [ __ ] floor
you're gonna somehow knock it over and I
do it every [ __ ] time and I was with
my son
and I was bouncing him on the exercise
ball and I finally got him to sleep and
the exercise ball was in between this
little crib so I kicked it backwards
with the with my [ __ ] you know my
heel and I just heard it I had a giant
like you know the [ __ ] workout level
bottle
I just heard it hit the ground and Gogu
you know that little father that sound
it makes and it's just the [ __ ] water
just pouring out and I was just like you
gotta be I wasn't screaming cuz anyone
wake up my kid but my wife heard it why
was that you know it's just like what
was that it was just it was just me
being me so anyway alright aggressively
woke girlfriend dumped me alright dear
Billy the I hate when you guys get me
nicknames that I don't understand Bella
cuz I feel like it's a good joke and I'm
ruining Bella cost Costco bingeing [ __ ]
and I gotta look up Bella Costco the
[ __ ] is that is this something that I
should know is there something I should
know alright be e Li cos Oh Bella Costco
Oh traditionally a short pyramid-shaped
cigar with a shorter more rounded taper
at the head is that what I call a
torpedo oh I like it oh there you go no
I think I get it well torpedo I think is
the other thing ones that are tapered at
both ends all right why you bring up
cigars can make me [ __ ] go smoke here
right I thought they said my tits it
says my title is a bit of book is a bit
of Clickbank but I got you this far so
no regrets
oh it's a bit of clickbait well and
reread see so I mean if this is just a
long boring one cuz I usually find that
that's what clickbait is it's just
[ __ ] boring alright my girlfriend or
I guess my ex-girlfriend now is a very
good person an absolutely beautiful
brilliant and caring sorry I can't stop
yawning here we are in medical school
together and we're dating for two years
everything was great initially we had oh
my god can you imagine the combined
student loan debt you guys would have we
had deep conversations and were each
other's best friends so when it came
time to pick a hospital for rotations we
chose one in her hometown and decided to
move in together
what could go wrong this sounds great so
far she was actually the stronger voice
in asking for the move for the move-in I
was down to do it but I didn't want to
upset her old school Catholic parents
because I figured that I should be on
their good side if I proposed in a year
or two that said for the past few months
she has gotten more and more progressive
to an intense degree we started having
political fights and I really didn't
feel heard
I'm left-wing but not as far as her Oh
for example my dad's mentally
handicapped cousin he had a virus when
he was little that messed up his brain
runs a liquor store in this state that
I'm not going to say yeah I just don't
like getting people in trouble here it
got burned down on the second night of
protesting riding after the gorge floor
after George Floyd got murdered our
classmates were talking about police
violence on our school message board so
I posted then I'm all for black lives
matter and the message systemic racism
is awful and needs to be stopped but
this violence has gotten out of hand and
needs to end I just asked for things to
be done peacefully yeah well you're kind
of confusing the rioters with the black
lives matter people that were protesting
you know and you're always gonna have
morons alright there's people on the
right politically that you can have a
conversation with and then there's [ __ ]
morons running around that dick out in
their four-wheeler talking about freedom
right and then he got on the left you
got [ __ ] people that he can
intelligent people you can have a
[ __ ] conversation with and then you
get these [ __ ] I don't know what the
[ __ ] you want to call him these people
like you know you should dress your son
in pink and give him a [ __ ] flower
just like I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about all right
she then comes over to me in our bedroom
and launches into this thing about how
saying that I'm diminishing the movement
and I need to not say these things to
other people yeah see this is where it
gets fit you what you shouldn't say what
you feel how I need to understand the
pain of black people the pain black
people are going through and offer
support how it's not time for my
comments cuz I'm white and I've never
had never felt systemic oppression on on
my side I'm pissed my dad and uncle are
now taking care of their cousin who has
had very little income due to kovat and
now doesn't even have a shop plus
there's some issues with insurance
because being covered for fire and theft
is different from being covered for a
riot I don't really get the financial
details but I do know that my dad has
had to postpone his retirement because
of all of this he's 70 years old and is
still working to provide for my family
of seven I told her I have a right to be
angry and voiced my opinions too I also
pointed out that calling for peace is
not disagreeing with the protesters
message I'm Jewish and have experienced
my fair share of anti-semitism the anger
I feel towards anti-semites would never
be an excuse to commit a violent act
against someone okay but in fairness
like the level of violence towards black
I don't think that Jewish people just
get pulled over for being Jewish you
know I mean historically obviously
you've been through some [ __ ] but you
know as far as your existence in this
country you don't I mean if you're gonna
if you get if you if you're gonna look
at like March Madness you know what are
you ranked in the brackets
all right I would say you're about an 11
seat anyways we've had other fights over
things like feminism 16 seed um oh Jesus
I'm gonna get [ __ ] for this I'm all for
equally equality between sexes and want
to do my part like taking on more
child-rearing responsibilities when I
have kids they be careful with that
buddy be careful with this because these
[ __ ] smartass women have basically
downloaded a bunch of [ __ ] that they
don't want to do anymore and have not
uploaded any of our [ __ ] jobs so the
guys kept all of their [ __ ] jobs and now
we're picking up their [ __ ] shifts also
and then they're [ __ ] sitting over
there they won't even make you a [ __ ]
sandwich anymore anyways but I refuse to
label myself as a feminist because I
think there's a lot of negative
man-hating ideologies associated with
that group it absolutely is they're
guilty of a lot of the things that
they're against not cool feminist ones
you can actually talk to they're very
rare like a cool sports fan that could
admit that his team you know got beat by
a better team it's very rare you know
I'm a bit of a [ __ ] when it comes to
being a sports fan I'm just a bit of a
[ __ ] in general anyways she is firm that
if I support women I need to label
myself as a feminist dude [ __ ] this
chick [ __ ] this chick otherwise I'm
denigrating her beliefs I responded that
I am a firm supporter of Israel's right
to exist but I would never label myself
as a Zionist because I think the
treatment of the Palestinians has been
horrendous all right dude you're really
coming off like a [ __ ] level-headed
person here granted I haven't been able
to hear what your your woman says here
your property kidding this all came to a
head the other day when after another
one of these political fights she dumped
me and went back to her parents place
now I'm paying the full rent on an
apartment that's way out of my price
range because she insisted on a
two-bedroom in a city where I don't know
anybody I'm
thousands of miles from my friends and
family and as a kicker
her dad is that she is a chief attending
at the hospital we're going to be
rotating at and either he or one of his
colleagues he will be directly in
control of my first clerkship grade he's
a very nice guy and has always been kind
to me but I still feel like I'm [ __ ]
I have no idea how he interpreted our
breakup and obviously had no control and
obviously have no control over his
response the worst part is I miss her a
lot and I'm more sad than angry
underneath all of this I think the wolf
stuff is an excuse to be mad at me yeah
I was kind of saying this is sort of a
weird thing to break up with somebody
over so she either wanted to do it or
just went off the deep end which happens
to people I went off the deep end in the
late 2000s early to go back and listen
to those podcasts and I was just talking
about the Federal Reserve and all of
this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
still don't think I'm wrong but I mean
that's that's not a place you want to be
mentally in it it just wears people out
around you anyways she has been upset
about my lack of effort in our
relationship for a few months she
constantly comments on how I don't take
her on dates anymore which has been hard
to do with kovat but honestly I have no
excuse dude you should do you're in
[ __ ] medical school you're in its
two-bedroom expensive [ __ ] goddamn
thing you guys have both buried in
[ __ ] student loans the [ __ ] is wrong
with this person
III don't know dude I I think you know
once you get past this [ __ ] you
listen if you have a shot in hell at
making a relationship work you gotta
find a sweetheart all right yeah this
this is uh this is the way you've
written us this is nuts
anyways I could have done more and I
could have been more invested
I [ __ ] up in that regard also her
parents are very religious so I think
moving in with me was a culture shock
and although she was the only one really
pushing for
moving I think it got scary because that
leap is a huge separation from her
parents in a childhood culture anyways
any advice you or Nia could lend would
be much appreciated I have no idea what
I'm gonna do for the next year I'm gonna
tell you exactly what the [ __ ] you gonna
do alright you're gonna go down to that
hospital and regardless of how her
[ __ ] dad treats you you're gonna
absolutely crush it that's what you're
gonna do okay and what are you gonna
prove to that man is that her daughter
was out of her [ __ ] mind to break up
with you now I'm not saying brown-nose
i'm just saying go in there and [ __ ]
kick the [ __ ] out of the job I would
even maybe I don't know address what
happened just be like hey sorry things
didn't work I mean she dumped you though
so I don't know I would just go in there
it's a year your [ __ ] life kick ass
it the [ __ ] job no matter what mind
game if the guy decides to play a mind
game which would be really [ __ ]
childish alright but you never know dad
with his daughter who the [ __ ] knows
right he might even been behind the
break-up you have no [ __ ] idea or or
there's a whole other way he might know
that she's out of her [ __ ] mind
who knows alright but I wouldn't bring
any [ __ ] baggage call the guy dr.
so-and-so whatever you know something if
he wants to [ __ ] bring it up let him
[ __ ] bring it up and I would like I
said I would just absolutely [ __ ]
crush it there you know you can always
break a lease you can always get a
[ __ ] roommate I'm sure you're gonna
meet somebody get a [ __ ] roommate do
not [ __ ] get another girlfriend this
quick and get him in there I wouldn't do
that either I would just get another
[ __ ] roommate you know I don't know
do the prison workout keep yourself in
shape and I don't know if you still
really like this chick maybe keep like a
[ __ ] open mind but I you know you
definitely got to draw some lines and
get some boundaries if you're gonna get
back together alright just tell her
straight up like listen you were a
sweetheart and I wanted to spend the
rest of my life with you and I
definitely dropped the ball in some
areas which I believe we've covered
you know because God knows she puck and
read you the riot act but you can
reiterate him so she can feel validated
and then you can delve into her [ __ ] and
just be like yeah listen you know this
world according to GARP [ __ ] lunatic
[ __ ] that you've gone on to add and
like she's not gonna internet reference
whatever the [ __ ] references okay you
know I haven't arrived uh I am a human
being and I have all emotions and I have
access to all of them and I have a right
to feel them okay and if I extend that
courtesy to you you need to extend it to
me and that's it and if I can be adult
enough to listen to your opinion that I
do not agree with okay but I'll be
mature enough to understand that you're
allowed to have that opinion then you
need to do that to me and if you can't
do that I'm not starting this over again
and I'll tell you this right now buddy
that's the best you're gonna do with
that one all right because this happens
with people's they they get into [ __ ]
and they go off the [ __ ] deep end God
knows I've done it and it's not fair to
the people in your life so sorry that
happened to you good luck but here's the
thing dude at the end of all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna be a doctor
okay and it's always sad right after
somebody breaks up with you but you
never know you might get back together
or you might not get back together and
one day you're gonna sit back and be
like what enough [ __ ] was I doing in
that thing putting up with that level of
[ __ ]
telling me what I can and can't [ __ ]
think I mean that chick is out of her
[ __ ] mind the way you wrote it you
know although you're not allowed to say
that nowadays you're supposed to say
that she's really strong you know what
it was you weren't a strong enough man
to handle her telling you what your
[ __ ] opinion should be Jesus Christ
what kind of [ __ ] world do we live in
it what kind of world are we living in
that [ __ ] gets taken away from people
you know some of this bull I don't know
I try to dance around this [ __ ] cuz I
don't want to get involved in this stuff
but you know III don't get this III just
I don't understand what the [ __ ] goes on
with these
I know we'll just leave it there with
this whole [ __ ] woke thing just whole
woke thing remember that was like like
black people came up with that and
somehow white people hijacked it it's
just a way to [ __ ] you know is it's
just this way to just show what a great
person they are with without really
doing anything like going after the name
of an airport mean with the flow what
kind of [ __ ] effort does that take
alright I guess maybe a little bit of an
effort I don't [ __ ] know you know
what I'm old and I'm gonna shut the [ __ ]
up god bless everybody god bless you god
bless him god bless her god bless
[ __ ] day and God bless people that
are wearing masks again you know let's
give this another try this this trying
to beat this [ __ ] virus it's gonna be
like you know it's like dieting we're
gonna we're gonna yo-yo diet our whole
way through it would be like [ __ ]
Bill Clinton you know be disgustingly
skinny or just have big [ __ ] hips
throughout all of this and hopefully
these genius scientists and doctors are
gonna [ __ ] figure out how to isolate
this thing and [ __ ] I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is they do you know shout
out to all the mice that are losing
their lives so we can continue to live
alright see you